pas passer au deuxième tour qu'il
fallait pas louper et là c'est vraiment
c'était du caviar
la cérémonie du ballon d'or on espérait
tous qu'un français remporte le titre
et voilà qui récompense le meilleur
footballeur de la saison alors déjà
c'est pas un français qui l'a remporté
et moi j'ai pensé voilà antoine
griezmann voilà si tu vois je t'embrasse
centre hérault mois voilà vous le savez
antoine griezmann c'est mon pote mais
moins vrai celui vraiment qu'il le
méritait pas ces antoine griezmann oui
il aurait dû être deuxième ou premier
essai raphaël varane qui avait gagné la
ligue des champions avec le real c'est
l'été a gagné qui a été champion du
monde il termine 7ème ça dérangeait pas
compris j'étais énervé toute la soirée
ça m'a foutu le maire d'orange ou sur
une table donc c'est luca modric le
croate qui rien contre lui il joue très
bien voilà il très sympa je connais pas
mais j'aimerais tellement de connaître
on vous a résumé cette soirée en vidéo
regardez c'est complètement ouf il ya eu
que des trucs de bananes c'était un
homme pas choisi n'importe quoi la
soirée ça fait 1 million 2 mais c'était
une catastrophe on va revenir dessus
juste après et je peux vous dire qu'elle
la rigolade sur ce soir et on va rigoler
regard des petits rica
hier soir au grand palais à paris
c'était la grande cérémonie du ballon
d'or france football 2018 ou comment
passer pour des gros en garde dans plus
de 120 pays à travers le monde
oui parce que hier on a eu des buts
[Applaudissements]
mais surtout des malaises voulait jouer
en équipe de france on vous demande de
ramener la coupe à la maison et vous
ramenez la coupe à la maison les bien
d'accord c'est sa mère
bref comme nous modric s'est vraiment
demandé ce qu'il faisait là
à part se manger des vents par vj dream
clairement l'étape la plus difficile
dans sa conquête du trophée aura été de
se taper toute la cérémonie
le ballon d'or france football 2018
l'eau car sinon pour la première fois
hier été décernés le meilleur espoir de
l'année de moins de 21 ans
j'étais vraiment très très content de
recevoir ce prix ça c'est vraiment très
content de recevoir ce prix
mais l'histoire retiendra qui hier pour
la première fois dans l'histoire du
ballon d'or un ballon d'or féminin une
ode aux femmes auquel martin solveig a
également voulu rendre hommage
est ce que tu sais at work et au malaise
bref la cérémonie du ballon d'or quand
c'était enfin fini on s'est tous dit
qu'ils étaient tandis qu'à gaza un
million deux cent mille téléspectateurs
à rayonner sur twitter ça a été un
donnez moi le nom de la personne qui a
décidé de penser que ginola sur un bon
présentateur c'est une catastrophe
bon ça c'est un peu dur qu'à catastrophe
ginola en tant que présentateur fort et
vrai ça sérieux parce que c'est hype
autour de lui c'est pas il sait pas
faire voilà pire animateurs ginola ces
terribles sérieusement en plus il met
david ginola présentateur moi je trouve
qu'il a son style après cérémonial bien
rire et je suis pas je ne suis pas et
des meilleurs footballeurs objectif
voilà je vous voilà enfin faut se méfier
des phénomènes de mode encore une fois
les faits une fois une émission à deux
ans a appris un peu les beaux gosses
c'est rigolo maintenant mais partout
malheureusement voilà la télévision
qu'on aime ou pas je dis pas ça pour
nous pour les autres c'est un métier ça
s'apprend il va trop vite trop loin mais
sur toutes les émissions
on voit bien que quand c'est très écrit
s'en sort quand là il faut un petit peu
de répartie j'irai du direct et tout
c'est pas son métier si on avait un
doute ça se voit ici ça s'apprend je
suis pas leur malaise
je suis désolé parce que vous c'est
votre pote vous ne dites ce que vous
avez à dire mais vous n'êtes pas que
l'animateur s'est pas promené le
problème du ballon d'or là je suis
désolé c'est pas ginola
mais lui c'est sort pas tout ça c'est la
cérémonie en elle-même
ils ont joué le ballon d'or ils ont mis
les gens sur des chaises pliantes de
jardin dans le grand palais a sonné le
vide l'autre l'autre crétin je le dis
franchement crétins le 2 le martin
soleil super-six dit non mais qui ne
pouvait pas dire si je retire très rare
et que c'était tout le monde me dit ah
ah ah la jeune joueuse qui a gagné le
ballon d'or est ce que vous savez tout
est ok mais cyril c'est du sexisme à
l'établé jeanne meyer celano verges
la norvégienne ada et guerre berga
qu'elle décroche et donc le premier
ballon d'or féminin de l'histoire cette
récompense a été entaché par une
question voilà qu'on le cocon le
qualifiera de mauvais goût et ça c'est
que les gens ont dit moi je trouve
franchement ça n'a pas choqué ah ben oui
c'est maladroit
oui c'est malheureux mais c'est arrivé
c'est il a pour l'april aurait pu le
dire à garçon si sûr il s'est inscrit
par notre ami c'est pas votre ami c'est
maladroit ou pas alors elle a raison mad
men qui sait donc ce qui vous plaît
alors tu as vu tout à l'heure j'ai
préparé une petite célébration pour pour
qui des halles qui a super bien joué le
jeu et on s'est dit qu'on allait faire
un truc un peu comme ça est ce que tu
sais tout marqué
ok alors on a alors on va là on la
remercie dire aussi que moi j'ai assisté
à j'étais invité une année et c'est
extrêmement masculin très masculin en
tant que femme
quand tu vas une résine cérémonie de
remises de ballon d'or tu t'es presque
gêné tellement il ya peu de femmes alors
l'ambiance est très s'excuser derrière
martin solveig regarder s'excuser après
la cérémonie
minelli des scouts piscine à cette
chaîne en france c'est soit un job
baroin
[Applaudissements]